hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein wunsch rezept von murat
und zwar mache ich einen
rinderschmorbraten mit bohnen und
kartoffeln und das ist ein richtig gutes
rezept wir haben das letztes jahr zu
weihnachten da waren wir uns von
freunden und die hatten das am vortag
gemacht und hatte murat teils da kommt
das schmuggeln wir uns jetzt ein als es
immerhin zum essen und hat ihm so gut
geschmeckt dass ich das jetzt heute für
ihn kochen soll genau und normalerweise
machen wir diesen schwung geraten mit
rotwein oder was sonst genau also
normalerweise keine mittel rotwein mit
drei audi die eurozone gut rein gemacht
genau super geschmeckt
der war richtig lecker ich glaube mit
drei tagen ist 23 er eigentlich schon
weil die sicherheitsziele gewesen und
ich mache das jetzt auch heute für etwa
acht personen
wir sind aber heute nur zu viert aber
wir essen das heißt es ist ein rezept
ihr könnt zwar bereit und zwei tage
davon essen schmeckt wirklich am zweiten
tag genau so gut wären ersten ich find's
toll in israel ist macht wenn man besuch
bekommt immer weiß ist komm ja total
vor allem hat man also das sind jetzt so
etwa dreieinhalb stunden vier stunden am
stück die man für dieses rezept braucht
aber zweieinhalb stunden davon beziehen
halbstunden davon muss man eh nichts
machen weil das ganze dann im ofen vor
sich hin sport und man kann in der zeit
schon mal sich hübsch machen oder sind
wir stecken ganz viele andere sachen ja
auf jeden fall zeige ich nicht mal eben
prinzip zutaten lied ist inzwischen
deftiges auf jeden fall also ich brauche
dafür rindfleisch und zwar 17 kilo
rindfleisch vom bug dann habe ich drei
bandscheiben einen dieser gemüse fleisch
sprühen
dann habe ich recht bohnen als olivenöl
tomatenmark salz und pfeffer dann hab
ich da vorne ein esslöffel oregano
rosmarin blätter uns wie beim fleisch
ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass ihr das
rindfleisch vom flug nehmen denn das
eignet sich hervorragend zum anbraten
und zum schmoren
und ja die dreibeinstativ mittelgroß und
das rezept bereich wirklich locker für
acht leute und dazu braucht ihr später
noch einen schmortopf
so erhöht sich erstmal die pfanne und
muss es leider erst mal anbraten
so jetzt gebe ich etwas olivenöl in die
heiße pfanne könnten zum beispiel dies
blöd oder sonnenblumenöl nehmen das ist
ziemlich viel was man das ganz scharf
von allen seiten anbraten
ich glaube ich fange jetzt aber mit den
beiden scheiben an
und so bekommen wir eben schön die
röstaromen mit rein
stecher damit so viel fleisch einen
kleinen pinkfarbenen november mit zu
männlich seine vertriebs beträgen
befindet richtig männlich und verbreitet
ist alles meine stücke an und gibt sie
dann direkt in den topf dann will ich
mal gespannt
übrigens hier den rand etwas ein
schneidet gerade hier wo die szenen sind
dann bleibt das fleisch auch schön flach
in der pfanne legen
das gleicht sich jetzt angebraten und
die untere schicht habe ich jetzt
komplett belegt mit diesem wein scheiben
und bevor ich jetzt aber sie wird mir
dazu gebe
wird sich das erstmal mit salz und
pfeffer und das fleisch hatte ich vorher
übrigens bereits eine stunde vorher aus
dem kühlschrank gelegt damit einfach
nicht mehr kühlschrank kalt sondern fast
immer warme wasser nicht aber soeben mit
salz und pfeffer und da kann man
eigentlich auch ganz ordentlich willst
du später kommen ja noch kartoffeln
wieder zu und die nehmen ja die sitze
dann auch noch bisher weg den rundbau
und den jetzt aufgerufen
und jetzt kann ich in dieser pfanne die
benutzte natürlich weiter wegen den
aromen kann ich jetzt bereits die bohnen
noch anbraten
die zwiebeln könnte jetzt entweder
innviertel schneiden dann verfahren sind
oder ihr zweites zum beispiel den fall
bringen
die meisten halten
die bohnen geben das direkt übers gleis
und ich finde einfarbig jetzt schon
richtig schön
dann kommt noch mal ein bisschen
olivenöl in die pfanne und da werden
jetzt die zwiebeln angebraten und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich hier business euro
zu den zwiebeln gebe ich jetzt noch das
tomatenmark mit dazu das kann ich auch
noch kurz mit anbraten
später so ein bisschen jahre automatisch
fruchtig perfekt sehr gut dazu und dann
lösche ich es auch schon direkt mit der
gm mit der fleischbrühe ab
die gewürze gebe ich jetzt einfach hier
betreiben dann verteilen sie sich
nämlich auch gut das ist nur einmal kurz
aufkochen damit sich das tomatenmark
auch gut lösen kann
so jetzt kann ich direkt die brühe mit
zum fleisch geben und darauf achten
immer von euch weg gießen und der tops
und jetzt mindestens bis zur hälfte mit
der flüssigkeit bedeckt sein also bei
mir ist es wirklich genau perfekt und an
dieser stelle könnt ihr natürlich vorher
nochmal die fleischbrühe abschmecken ob
genug salz drinnen ist also wenn sie
grad gut ist müsste dann wirklich noch
mal ein bisschen mehr salz dazugeben
denn die bohnen sind nicht gewürz und
später kommen ja noch mal kartoffeln mit
rein und die neben wirklich das ganze
salz und gewürze weg jetzt kommt der
deckel drauf
da kommt es so erst mal den backofen in
den vorgeheizten backofen den habe ich
schon auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
gestellt und da stelle ich diesen
beraten jetzt erst einmal für eineinhalb
stunden rein und nach eineinhalb stunden
kommen die kartoffel mit dazu aber das
leben seiner mutter schickte rad in die
röhre
da freuen wir uns richtig drauf weil die
tolles aussieht welche auch der braten
ist das noch im ofen aber da ist schon
fertig also eineinhalb stunden sind
schon vergangen
ihr könnt aber auch wenn es mal öffnet
und das fleisch ist noch nicht ganz
soweit könnte es auch ruhig länger drin
lassen
jetzt habe ich die kartoffeln bereits
geschehen ist es ist ein kilo geschältes
gewicht und jetzt schneide ich die in
dicke scheiben in dem schreiben deswegen
das jetzt nicht zu weich werden beim
garen
denn ich werde jetzt noch mal etwa für
eine stunde mit drei schieben die
chancen so etwa 1 cm dick
jetzt kann ich den beraten erst mal raus
holen
wow
jetzt kommen da die kartoffel noch mit
drauf es sieht jetzt natürlich schon mal
richtig genial aus und wenn man dann die
kartoffel noch dabei hat und die bohnen
da braucht man auch wirklich keine
weitere beilage also man braucht weder
nudeln noch irgendwas das ist wirklich
ein komplettes rezept so deckel wieder
drauf und dann noch mal für eine stunde
in den backofen und dann ist der park
endlich sitzt
jetzt ist der braten fertig und wir sind
alle gespannt wie er aussehen
es riecht schon mal richtig gut unsere
freunde sind jetzt auch schon auf dem
weg den wir werden ihn jetzt gleich ob
wir sind dann acht leute 88 ein halber
also jetzt mal ein paar kartoffeln reis
und bohnen
moritz als erster probieren
okay ein richtiger sonntagsbraten will
ich sagen oder oder auch schon schon
weihnachten ostern alles oder ja doch
eigentlich unserem festtagsessen
stückler ab und wenn man das übrigens am
nächsten tag noch essen möchte ein stück
echt mit der kamera reinkommen ich finde
man sieht hier schon richtig wie zartes
fleisch
plötzlich fällt echt schon fast
auseinander
euch liebt des mähdreschers severin
zusammen also finde es auch richtig cool
und witzig spritzig auf ganz einfach
gemacht geld ja eigentlich schon
also ist es nur 175 grad und der murat
darf direkt probieren
ok ich probiert also wichtig ist
natürlich 100 prozent daraus als
wichtigsten festkochende kartoffeln
keine medico was genau dann bleiben sie
auch schon zusammen sagt da jetzt mal
ein wenig kohle gekauft und festkochende
aber ich verstehe unsere städten luxor
igor schmidt richtig
so sieht ein richtiger brauche wirklich
nichts anderes dazu also das reicht
vollkommen
ich denke möhren würden hier drin noch
richtig gut schmecken vor allem wenn man
die einfach so in paar stücke schneidet
also richtig groß lässt man sehen ja
auch noch bissfest um hat man richtig
tolle sauce mit dabei und ich finde es
auch sehr gut und ich würde sagen wir
warten jetzt noch länger decken unseren
tisch und essen das gleich zusammen und
falls rudd nach machen wollt dann geht
aufs eis - dog days stets noch mal ganz
genau und ich freue mich wenn ihr das
nachmacht das sollte auf jeden fall tun
vielleicht schon diesen sonntag
und hier sehe ich dass ich sehr scharf
angebraten hat und es richtig dass
fahrzeuge hier
das ist so genial und nimmst sowie ab
weil ich kann es gar nicht beschreiben